One of the interesting things
about learning to use Core Data is
the chance to see
an entire NBC architecture,
as envisioned by some
of Apple's developers.
In this last Core Data lesson we want
to look at a particular issue for NBC.
How should the view code be
notified when the model is updated?
Core Data encourages two techniques,
NSNotificationCenter and
NSFetchResultsController.
You may recall NSNotificationCenter
from the networking course, but
this FetchResultsController is new and
pretty cool, we think you'll like it.
We recommend that you use
the FetchResultsController
in the Virtual Tourist app.
In this lesson we'll show you how
it works in a similar app, and
at the end of the lesson,
we think that you'll be ready to
tackle the fourth portfolio project.